MY MAMA THINKS I WAS BORN
TO BE A TOP MODEL.
AND SOMEHOW,
I GOT FROM THIS...
TO THIS.
ARE TOP MODELS
BORN OR MADE?
YOU'RE NOT BORN A TOP MODEL,
I CAN TELL YOU THAT.
YOU HAVE TO WORK FOR IT.
OUR LAST THREE WINNERS
STUDIED, STRUGGLED...
I'M NOT FINISHED!
AND WENT ALL OUT...
- EVA.
- (squealing)
TO ACHIEVE THEIR DREAMS.
NOW THOUSANDS MORE
SENT ME THEIR TAPES,
HOPING I MIGHT SEE THEIR
TOP MODEL POTENTIAL.
WHO WILL GO FROM
AN UNKNOWN TO A TOP MODEL?
THESE GIRLS BETTER WORK IT,
STARTING RIGHT NOW!
MY NAME'S NOELLE,
AND I'M WAY EXCITED.
I AM READY TO COMPETE AGAINST
THE MOST GORGEOUS GIRLS
I'LL PROBABLY
EVER SEE IN MY LIFE.
I'M KAHLEN,
AND I JUST LANDED IN L.A.
IT'S A LITTLE WEIRD.
I NEVER BEEN HERE BEFORE.
I'M A SMALL TOWN GIRL,
SO THIS IS CRAZY.
♪♪♪
MY NAME IS BRITTANY, AND
I'M FROM TALLAHASSEE, FLORIDA.
THIS IS WHAT I WANTED DO
SINCE DAY ONE OF MY LIFE.
WHATEVER IT TAKES TO WIN,
BABY! I'M IN!
I'M BRANDY.
THIS IS MY FIRST TIME
RIDIN' A PLANE.
THIS IS JUST, LIKE,
TOTALLY TRIPPING ME OUT.
- LLUVY.
- LLUVY? KAHLEN.
I'M LLUVY, AND I WAS
BORN IN MEXICO.
NOW I'M JUST
A CALIFORNIA GIRL.
MY NAME IS TIFFANY.
I'M FROM MIAMI, FLORIDA.
AND I AM SO EXCITED TO BE
HERE FOR A SECOND CHANCE.
WHAT'S UP?
FIRST TIME I CAME HERE,
AND I GOT IN A FIGHT.
(screaming)
THAT STANK HO
POURED A BEER ON MY WEAVE!
I CAME BACK--
I AM NOT GOING TO SAY
A DIFFERENT PERSON--
BUT IN A LOT OF WAYS
I'M A BETTER PERSON.
I KNOW I HAVE TO DO GOOD
THIS TIME.
♪♪♪
I AUDITIONED
FOR THE LAST COMPETITION,
AND I DIDN'T MAKE IT.
- TOCCARA.
- WHOO!
IT RIPPED MY HEART OUT.
I TRIED OUT AGAIN.
THIS IS MY SECOND CHANCE,
AND I AM NOT WASTING
ANYTHING WITH THIS ONE.
♪♪♪
THE FIRST TIME I SAW
EVERYONE ALL TOGETHER
WAS WHEN WE ALL MET
IN A BIG ROOM,
AND EVERYONE WAS KINDA
CHECKING EACH OTHER OUT
AND TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHO'S THEIR COMPETITION.
HELLO.
- (screaming)
- (applause)
SO WELCOME TO L.A.
AND WELCOME TO THE WESTIN
CENTURY PLAZA HOTEL.
TAKE A LOOK
AROUND THIS ROOM.
SOMEONE HERE IS AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
(applause)
YOU GUYS BETTER GET YOUR
GAME ON AND BRING IT, OKAY?
GET A SPACE IN THIS HOUSE.
SO WHAT DO YOU THINK
TYRA IS LOOKING FOR?
I THINK SHE IS LOOKING
FOR SOMEONE REALLY UNIQUE.
SOMEBODY THAT'S REAL.
SOMEBODY THAT CAN
BRING SOMETHING NEW.
I THINK SHE'S LOOKING
FOR ME.
- OH, ALL RIGHT.
- I KNOW WHAT I AM LOOKING FOR.
- (screaming)
- (applause)
♪♪♪
I SAW EVERY SINGLE GIRL'S
TAPE IN HERE.
I REMEMBER
THERE IS A GIRL IN HERE
WHO FEELS LIKE SHE
ONCE WAS A CAT
AND IS NOW
REINCARNATED AS A WOMAN.
- RAWR.
- THIS IS HER.
ISN'T YOUR NICKNAME LADY KAT
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT?
OH, MY GOSH!
I AM LOOKING FOR GIRLS
WITH PIZZAZZ.
I AM LOOKING FOR GIRLS THAT
ARE BEAUTIFUL ON THE OUTSIDE,
BUT, DUH, MOST MODELS ARE
BEAUTIFUL ON THE OUTSIDE.
BUT I AM LOOKING FOR
THE BEAUTY ON THE INSIDE.
SOMETHING THAT IS RARE,
SOMETHING
THAT IS EXTRA SPECIAL.
JUST BE ON BUT BE YOURSELVES.
DON'T FAKE IT.
I CAN SEE THROUGH
THE FAKE, OKAY?
SO JUST BE REAL.
- BYE-BYE.
- (screaming)
SHE REALLY CARED.
SHE CAME.
IT TOTALLY
PUMPED US UP FOR THE WEEK.
♪♪♪
WITH SO MANY GIRLS
TO CHOOSE FROM,
I'M RELYING ON THE HELP OF MY
VERY OPINIONATED COLLEAGUES.
MR. JAY MANUAL,
THE CREATIVE DIRECTOR
OF ALL OF OUR PHOTO SHOOTS.
I LOVE WHERE IT'S GOING,
BUT IT'S LOOKING
A LITTLE HOOTCHIE.
AND MISS J. ALEXANDER...
POSTURE. BALANCE.
OUR RUNWAY COACH
AND DIVA EXTRAORDINAIRE.
IT'S ABOUT TO FALL, BUT
YOU'RE NOT LETTING IT HAPPEN.
- IT'S NOT GONNA FALL.
- OH, OH!
COME ON IN, REBECCA.
MY NAME IS REBECCA.
I'M 21, AND I'M FROM
MINNEAPOLIS, MINNESOTA.
I LOVE THIS GIRL
SO MUCH.
I AM ACTUALLY
ON MY WAY TO BEING MARRIED
AND HAVING THE KIDS.
BUT BEFORE I DO THAT,
I WANT TO HAVE FUN.
YOU HAVE A VERY ALL-AMERICAN,
SLIGHTLY CALIFORNIA LOOK.
HOW DO YOU SEE YOURSELF
BEING ABLE TO TRANSFORM?
SWEET INNOCENCE IS
KIND OF MY COVER UP,
AND I CAN DO SOME THINGS
AND STILL GET AWAY WITH IT.
(gasps)
I HAVE LIED AND CHEATED
AND, YOU KNOW,
GOTTEN MY WAY.
BUT I WANT PEOPLE TO SEE ME
AS A GOOD, SWEET,
INNOCENT PERSON
BECAUSE IT'S ALWAYS
WORKED IN MY FAVOR.
I WAS VERY IMPRESSED
WITH HER.
LIKE SHE WAS A VERY SWEET GIRL,
BUT SHE'S GOT SOME GRIT.
- HI, EVERYBODY.
- HI.
MY NAME IS KEENYAH.
I AM STUDYING BIOLOGY
AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA, RIVERSIDE.
OKAY, WELL,
THIS IS MY STREET.
I LIVE WITH MY FAMILY DURING
THE SUMMERTIME IN COMPTON.
THE MEDIA
REPRESENTS COMPTON
TO BE THIS PLACE WHERE YOU
WALK OUTSIDE, YOU GET SHOT.
SO IF SOMEBODY WERE
TO SEE ME ANYWHERE
AND SAY, "OH,
SHE'S FROM COMPTON?
OH, I DIDN'T KNOW THAT THIS
CAN COME FROM COMPTON."
BUT REMEMBER,
YOU REPRESENT YOU.
YOU CAN INSPIRE PEOPLE
AND SAY THAT YOU CAME
FROM THERE,
BUT YOU WILL
REPRESENT WHO YOU ARE.
- SO REMEMBER THAT.
- RIGHT.
IF IT CAME BETWEEN MODELING
AND BEING A DOCTOR,
I WOULD ABSOLUTELY
CHOOSE MODELING.
THE WAY YOU CAN
REPRESENT YOURSELF
WITHOUT SAYING A WORD,
I THINK THAT IS SO EXCELLENT.
HEY, Y'ALL.
I'M KAHLEN.
I'M FROM BROKEN ARROW,
OKLAHOMA.
YOU'VE NEVER SEEN
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"?
NO, I DON'T WATCH
A LOT OF TV.
WE ONLY HAVE,
LIKE, THREE CHANNELS,
AND I WORK 50 HOURS
A WEEK.
I DON'T KNOW MUCH
ABOUT THE FASHION
AND HOW TO WALK
OR HOW TO POSE FOR PICTURES.
I WAS'NT SURE IF I COULD
ACTUALLY DO IT.
WALK TOWARD US AND BACK.
MM. MM-HMM.
THANK YOU, KAHLEN.
SHE'S WATCHING EVERY EPISODE
OF "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
- WITH THAT WALK.
- YOU KNOW WHAT?
THAT WAS CARMEN CASS.
AND THAT WAS WIND
IN YOUR HAIR.
WE LIKE.
MY NAME IS LINDSEY, I'M FROM
BATON ROUGE, LOUISIANA,
AND I AM 21.
MY FAMILY WAS MORMON.
BIG MORMON FAMILY,
VERY CLOSE KNIT.
BUT I DON'T BELIEVE IN GOD
AT THIS POINT IN MY LIFE.
I TOLD MY MOTHER
THAT I WAS ATHEIST,
AND SHE SAID THAT SHE WOULD
RATHER HAVE HEARD
THAT I WAS
PREGNANT OR A LESBIAN.
WELL, I AM FLABBERGASTED.
AFTER PARTING WAYS
WITH THE MORMON RELIGION,
I DID CHANGE THE WAY
THAT I SAW MYSELF.
I KIND OF STARTED TO GO OUT
A LITTLE BIT MORE,
STARTED TO CARE A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT HAIR AND MAKEUP.
- THANK YOU.
LOVE THE LEGS,
LOVE THE STRUT,
NEEDS A HAIR CUT.
HER HAIR LOOKS LIKE A WIG
THAT YOU BOUGHT IN A STORE
FOR $19.99,
AND IT'S CALLED A NANCY.
YOU KNOW HOW THEY ALL
GOT A NAME? HER WIG--
YOU KNOW THERE'S
A TYRA WIG OUT THERE.
SHE SHOULD HAVE GONE
AND BOUGHT THE TYRA.
- HI.
- YOUR FOREHEAD IS GORGEOUS.
MY SISTER
WITH A BIG FOREHEAD.
- I KNOW.
- WE LOVE THAT.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER AND I'M
FROM RICHMOND, CALIFORNIA.
WHEN I WAS YOUNGER,
I REALLY DIDN'T HAVE
A LOT OF SELF-CONFIDENCE.
BUT OVER THE YEARS,
I REALLY FOUND
A PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH GOD,
AND THAT'S MADE ME
A VERY STRONG PERSON.
IF YOU BELIEVE IN SOMETHING,
AND ESPECIALLY
IF YOU BELIEVE IN YOURSELF,
YOU CAN BE ANYTHING.
HELLO.
HOW ARE ALL YOU
FABULOUS PEOPLE DOING TODAY?
'CAUSE I KNOW I AM DOING
VERY WELL, THANK YOU.
I AM BRITTANY.
I AM 22 YEARS OLD.
- HI.
- DID YOU HAVE RED BULL
THIS MORNING?
NO, I AM ALWAYS
LIKE THIS.
I'M LIKE, WHOO!
- I AIN'T MAD AT YOU.
- DING, DING, DING.
I'M A WINNER.
I LOVE BEING OUTGOING,
I'M EXTREMELY OUTSPOKEN,
I WANT TO BE THE CENTER
OF ATTENTION.
I NEED TO ENTERTAIN.
I'VE MUST HAVE BEEN
A DRAG QUEEN IN A FORMER LIFE.
I LOVE BIG HAIR.
I'M ALL ABOUT SOME BIG HAIR.
WOW. MAYBE I WILL GET
A SEX CHANGE
SO I CAN BE A DUDE
SO I CAN DO DRAG.
I ALREADY HAVE THE VOICE.
HELLO, I AM MANLY STANLEY.
THANK YOU.
I WOULD LOVE TO PUT HER
AND JANICE IN A ROOM TOGETHER
AND JUST SHUT THE DOOR.
I THINK BRITTANY
MIGHT COME OUT ALIVE.
- SOMEBODY'S BACK.
- HEY. I'M BACK.
I'M TIFFANY.
I'M FROM MIAMI, FLORIDA,
AND I'M 21 YEARS OLD.
LAST TIME I CAME HERE
I TRIED OUT,
I DIDN'T GET IN.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
A BIG CHANGE
FROM HUSTLING TO BEIN'
A GLAMOUR GIRL ANYWAY.
IT'S COOL. YOU KNOW,
I'M USED TO FAILING.
SOMEBODY GOT TO FAIL, RIGHT?
THE LAST TIME I WAS HERE,
I KNEW I HAD TO BE
CHANGING MY LIFE.
I DON'T JUMP ON PEOPLE
AND THROW GLASSES
AND STUFF LIKE THAT ANYMORE.
I'M JUST NOT LIKE THAT
ANYMORE, I'M JUST NOT,
AND I'M GLAD I'M NOT.
I WENT BACK HOME AND I WENT
TO MY ANGER MANAGEMENT CLASS.
THAT HELPED A LOT.
EVERYTHING IN MY LIFE
IS HAPPY.
I HAVE A LOT OF HELP
WITH MY BABY NOW,
MY BOYFRIEND IS WONDERFUL.
HE'S GREAT.
I'M HAPPY.
I'M A HAPPY PERSON.
GO ON AND CRY, BABY.
GO ON AND CRY.
- I'M HAPPY.
- WHY YOU TEARIN' UP?
I'M STRONG.
BECAUSE I WAS THINKING--
I WAS LAYING IN THE BED,
AND I'M, LIKE, I'M LAYING
IN BEVERLY HILLS AGAIN.
AND I SLEEP AT HOME WITH
MY BABY IN A TWIN SIZE BED,
AND I WAS JUST WISHING MY BABY
AND MY GRANDMOTHER--
I REALLY WISH
SHE COULD SEE THIS
'CAUSE SHE AIN'T GOT NO MONEY,
SHE, UM...
THE LAST TIME I WAS HERE,
THEY SAID THAT I NEEDED
TWO BATHING SUITS,
AND SHE WENT AND
SHE BOUGHT ME BATHING SUITS.
THE DAY BEFORE I LEFT,
I WAS, LIKE, GRANDMA, WELL--
YOU KNOW, WHY THE LIGHTS
WENT OFF OR WHATEVER?
SHE WAS, LIKE,
BECAUSE, GIRL,
SOMEBODY AIN'T GETTING PAID
'CAUSE YOU GOIN'.
MY GRANDMOTHER LET THE LIGHTS
GO OFF TO BUY ME A BATHING SUIT.
I LOVE HER SO MUCH.
I JUST WANT TO SHOW MY SON
AND MY FAMILY AS WELL
THAT I CAN DO BETTER.
TIFFANY GRABBED
HER PROBLEMS BY THE REINS.
SHE GOT IT TOGETHER,
SHE CAME BACK,
AND I TRULY BELIEVED
THAT THAT GIRL WANTS
TO CHANGE HER LIFE.
BUT CAN SHE BE A MODEL?
♪♪♪
- OH, IT'S COLD!
- IT IS NOT COLD.
THAT NIGHT
DID THE POOL THING.
I AM GOING TO GET TO KNOW
SOME OF THESE GIRLS.
LIKE, NOW I'M GONNA GET
TO KNOW WHO IS COMPETITIVE.
WE GOT IN THE HOT TUB,
PLAYED SOME TRUTH OR DARE.
SOME PEOPLE GOT
A LITTLE CRAZY.
- ALL RIGHT.
- YOU TWO, RUN DOWN THERE,
SWITCH SWIM SUITS
AND COME BACK.
PEOPLE WERE SO SURPRISED
'CAUSE THEY THOUGHT,
I DON'T KNOW,
JUST BECAUSE I WAS PLUS,
I WOULD BE SHY
ABOUT MY BODY.
BUT I WAS RIPPING OFF
MY CLOTHES.
THIS IS NOT
"GIRLS GONE WILD."
- (applause)
- YOU GO, GIRL!
I AM JUST GONNA BE EXACTLY
WHO I AM.
ME AND A FEW OF THE GIRLS
WERE JUST, LIKE, POLE DANCES!
I'M, LIKE, GUYS, THAT IS NOT
THE WAY TO GO.
OH, LET'S GET NAKED.
OH, MY GOD!
I WASN'T SITTING THERE
TALKING TO PEOPLE AND GOING,
"YEAH, I AM FROM
TALLAHASSEE, WHEW."
I DON'T THINK
IT WAS A BIG DEAL,
BUT I LIKE TO SEE PEOPLE
DO CRAZY STUFF.
I DON'T FEEL I NEED
TO TAKE MY CLOTHES OFF.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S WHO
THESE GIRLS REALLY ARE.
I'M REALLY INTERESTED
TO SEE WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN
FROM HERE ON OUT.
- WE'RE ALL GOING TO GO OUT.
- WHOO!
I'M JUST TOTALLY PSYCHED.
IF YOU'RE 21 AND OVER,
YOU'RE GOIN'
TO THE TWO HOTTEST CLUBS
IN L.A.
IF YOU'RE UNDER 21,
IT'S A SURPRISE.
OH, YEAH.
I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
WHERE WE WERE.
I WAS LOOKIN'
AT THE STREET SIGNS.
I SAW SANTA MONICA
AND I SAW SUNSET.
SO THAT WAS REALLY EXCITING.
WE WENT
TO THE WHITE LOTUS.
IT WAS A LOT OF FUN,
ESPECIALLY TO GET OUT
AND JUST HAVE FRESH AIR.
WE'RE PRAYING, LIKE,
LET US GO TO THE CLUB,
LET US GO TO THE CLUB.
WHERE THE HELL ARE WE?
HUH.
BOWLING?
WHAT I'M GON' DO IN A...
I WAS LIKE,
I CAN'T EVEN BOWL.
♪♪♪
AND WE ARE GETTING
OUR FREAK ON.
HERE'S TO BEING 21.
NO BOWLING.
♪♪♪
WE ENDED UP
HAVING A BLAST.
IT TURNS OUT WE GOT TO STAY
LATER AT THE BOWLING ALLEY
THAN THEY GOT TO STAY
AT THE CLUB.
NEENER, NEENER, NEENER.
JUST ALL OVER THE PLACE.
OH, MY GOD, OH, MY GOD.
OH, MY GOD.
YOU WALKIN' IN HERE
LIKE YOU'RE NUTS.
MY NAME IS JESSICA.
I'M FROM HOUSTON, TEXAS,
AND I'M 21,
AND I'M KNOWN
AS LADY KAT. RAWR.
WHY DO YOU CALL YOURSELF
LADY KAT?
I HAVE LONG NAILS
AND I'LL SCRATCH.
YOUR FACE LOOKS KIND OF
CAT-LIKE TO ME, THE EYES.
YOU WANT TO SEE
THE CAT WALK?
- OH.
- HOLD UP.
- YEAH, WORK IT OUT.
- RAWR. MMM.
SALT TASTES GOOD.
I HOPE I'M GETTIN'
LOTS OF CHOCOLATE.
I'M AGGRESSIVE AND I AM,
I WON'T SAY ARROGANT,
BUT JUST THIS
PASSIONATE INDIVIDUAL.
- HOW TALL ARE YOU?
- I ACTUALLY--I DON'T KNOW.
- STAND UP, TYRA.
- TAKE YOUR SHOES OFF.
I CAN TELL YOU
HOW TALL YOU ARE.
- I'M 5'10".
- I THINK YOU'RE 5'9".
OH, MY GOD, I WAS STANDING--
CAN I TOUCH YOU?
OOH!
MY GOD. OH!
- BYE.
- RAWR.
DO YOU KNOW
WHAT'S SO FUNNY?
I DIDN'T REALIZE HOW
BEAUTIFUL HER SKIN IS
- WHEN SHE WALKED IN.
- SHE IS GORGEOUS.
I LIKED HER.
HI, I'M SARAH.
GROWING UP,
I WAS THE TOMBOY.
MY OLDER SISTER USED TO TELL ME
THAT I WASN'T REALLY PRETTY
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
YOU'RE NOT GOOD ENOUGH,
YOU'RE NOT PRETTY ENOUGH,
YOU'RE NOT TALL ENOUGH.
YOU KNOW, LIKE,
THAT SUCKS,
BUT YOU JUST MOVE ON.
VERY SKINNY AND STRAIGHT
AND NO BOOB, NO NOTHING,
NOT UNTIL I WAS, LIKE
16 YEARS OLD, 17 YEARS OLD
THAT I FINALLY GREW, LIKE,
A CHEST AT ALL.
I JUST KIND OF BLOSSOMED.
I GUESS IT JUST TOOK ME
A LITTLE WHILE.
- WHAT DOES THAT SAY?
- "HOLLA BACK," GIRL.
- HOLLA BACK.
- WHOO! WHOO!
SHE HAD A NICE WAIST.
I THOUGHT
SHE HAD GREAT SKIN.
REALLY BIG PERSONALITY,
FUN, FUN, FUN.
I JUST DIDN'T
HOLLA BACK.
HI, EVERYBODY,
I'M LLUVY.
SORRY.
I'M REALLY NERVOUS.
- LLUVY, IS THAT YOUR DRESS?
- MM-MMM.
- ACTUALLY, IT IS MY SISTER'S.
- I KNEW IT.
- I KNEW IT WASN'T YOURS.
- NO?
- YEAH. I COULD TELL.
- I AM A JEANS AND
A T-SHIRT GIRL.
I KNOW. DO YOU HAVE
JEANS AND T-SHIRT HERE?
CAN YOU GO BACK
AND PUT THOSE ON?
- YEAH.
- 'CAUSE I CAN TELL
THAT'S NOT YOU.
OH, THANK YOU.
I LOVE YOU.
THERE SHE IS.
YOU'RE YOURSELF RIGHT NOW.
YEAH. THANK YOU GUYS
SO MUCH. I APPRECIATE THAT.
WHEN I WAS A KID, I WENT
THROUGH BASICALLY EVERY STAGE
THAT YOU CAN THINK OF.
LLUVY, ON YOUR
APPLICATION IT SAYS
YOU USED TO BE IN A GANG.
OH, GOODNESS ME.
BEING IN A GANG AND
DOING ALL THAT STUFF--
I THINK IT'S THE WORST,
LIKE, STAGE OF MY LIFE.
I WAS JUST AN ANGRY KID.
IT'S SAD.
LIKE, I HATE
TALKING ABOUT IT
BECAUSE IT GETS ME
KINDA ALL LOOPY.
BUT I JUST HAD A LOT OF,
LIKE, RESENTMENT
AGAINST A LOT OF PEOPLE,
ESPECIALLY NOT HAVING
A DAD AND STUFF.
MY DAD PASSED AWAY
WHEN I WAS 3.
THE ONE THING THAT
I CLEARLY REMEMBER GROWING UP
IS MY MOM ALWAYS
TELLING ME,
"YOUR DAD ALWAYS
WANTED YOU TO BE A MODEL."
SO I JUST KNOW--I'M LIKE,
OKAY, I HAVE TO BE A MODEL.
I THINK SHE'S GREAT.
I LOVE HER.
HI, MY NAME IS MICHELLE.
I AM 18
AND I'M FROM INDIANA.
I AM PART OF THIS WRESTLING
FEDERATION IN INDIANA.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS.
AND USUALLY WHEN I GET UP
ON THE SIDE OF THE RING,
I DO A BACK FLIP
INTO IT OFF THE ROPE.
LIKE, THE GIRLS I WRESTLE
ARE, LIKE, 125 POUNDS,
AND I, LIKE, HAVE TO
BE ABLE TO PICK THEM UP
AND KIND OF, LIKE,
FLING 'EM AROUND.
I'LL GO OUT THERE
AND I'LL JUST, LIKE,
DO MY LITTLE POSE
AND EVERYONE'S, LIKE,
"BOO, BOO."
I LOVE WRESTLING A LOT.
BUT I WILL SACRIFICE THE
WRESTLING TO BECOME A MODEL.
I WANT TO BE THE NEXT
TYRA BANKS, DAMN IT.
LOST MY SHOE.
HOLD ON A SECOND.
♪ YEAH ♪
♪ AMERICA'S TOP MODEL
IS IN HERE, YEAH ♪
- WALK OUT.
- OH, NO! OH, NO, YOU DIDN'T.
TO BE, LIKE, AN
INSPIRATIONAL SPEACHER--
- SPEAK--
- MNH-MNH.
I AM NOT
A VIRGIN ANYMORE.
YOU AREN'T EITHER.
I DO THE BEYONCE.
OH, HERE GOES THE BEAT.
OOH, WAIT. UH, UH...
(classical music playing)
LOVE THE BLOOMERS.
HOW DO YOU PRONOUNCE
YOUR NAME?
NAIMA.
MY PARENTS
ARE MUSICIANS.
AND JOHN COLTRANE
IS A JAZZ MUSICIAN.
THEY NAMED ME AFTER
A COMPOSITION OF HIS
NAMED "NAIMA."
TELL ME ABOUT THIS MOHAWK.
I HAD LONG HAIR, AND
THERE WAS JUST SO MANY THINGS
I WAS CARRYING AROUND WITH ME
FROM MY PAST
AND MY CHILDHOOD AND
JUST CRAZINESS IN MY HEAD,
AND I JUST WANTED
TO GET RID OF IT.
I JUST KINDA WANTED
TO BECOME A MONK,
SO I JUST SHAVED MY HEAD.
AND I DECIDED A MOHAWK
WOULD BE IDEAL
SO IT COULD
CENSOR MY THOUGHTS.
HEY.
MY FELLOW REDHEAD SISTER.
POWER TO THE PEOPLE.
I'M BRANDY.
I'M 19, AND I AM
FROM HOUSTON, TEXAS.
CAN I JUST SAY SOMETHING?
I AM SO JEALOUS
OF YOUR HAIR
'CAUSE IT WAS JUST, LIKE,
BOUNCING LEFT AND RIGHT.
- IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
- THANK YOU.
YOURS IS BEAUTIFUL, TOO.
IT'S JUST NATURAL.
I BET YOUR HAIR,
STRAIGHTENED,
IT'D BE, LIKE,
WAY DOWN TO HERE.
NO, GIRL, IT'S NOT REAL.
IT IS NOT REAL?
- IT'S NOT REAL.
- WHAT IS IT?
IT'S SEWN IN.
MY MOTHER DID IT.
TELL YOUR MAMA
I AIN'T MAD AT HER.
THIS IS BRANDY.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE IT,
YOU AIN'T GOT TO LIKE IT,
BUT I LOVE IT AND LIKE IT
SO THAT'S ME.
COMPETITION--
THAT'S THE BIGGEST WORD
IN MY HEAD RIGHT NOW,
AND I AM GOING TO BE
ABOUT WINNING.
YOU NEED A SHIRT?
YOU SHOULDA BROUGHT
YOUR OWN.
MM-HMM.
- THANK YOU. BYE.
- BYE.
WALK? IT'S LIKE
SHE DIDN'T TRY AT ALL.
IT WAS LIKE SHE WAS WALKING
DOWN THE GROCERY LINE,
AND I'M GONNA GET
SOME CANNED PEACHES.
- LIKE, I DIDN'T FEEL LIKE--
- SOME CANNED PEACHES?
SERIOUSLY.
- HI.
MY NAME'S TATIANA
I'M FROM MAUI, HAWAII,
AND I'M 18.
ALOHA.
MAHALO.
I WAS DRIVING,
AND I HEARD IT ON THE RADIO.
THERE'S "TOP MODEL"
AUDITIONS IN OAHU.
AND I, LIKE,
WENT TO THE AIRPORT,
SPENT ALL MY RENT MONEY
ON A PLANE TICKET.
IF I WANT SOMETHING,
I WILL MAKE IT HAPPEN.
YOU SAID THAT YOU LEFT
HIGH SCHOOL.
I LIKE TO LEARN
BY MYSELF, BY, LIKE,
MAKING MY OWN MISTAKES.
I'M GONNA GO GET
MY G.E.D.
AND I'M GONNA PURSUE
WHAT I WANT TO DO,
- WHICH IS MODELING.
- THANK YOU.
- THANKS.
- THANK YOU, GUYS.
- I LIKE HER.
- AND SHE'S GOT PERSONALITY.
HI, MY NAME IS ESTELA.
I'M 22 YEARS OLD,
AND I AM FROM THE BRONX.
THIS WHOLE COMPETITION
IS INSIDE ME RIGHT NOW.
I JUST WANT IT SO BAD,
I TASTE IT.
THIS IS WHAT'S
GONNA GIVE ME
A BETTER LIFE FOR ME
AND MY BABY GIRL.
HOW OLD IS YOUR DAUGHTER?
SHE'S GONNA BE
3 YEARS OLD.
I GOT MARRIED AT 18,
AND WE WERE VERY MUCH IN LOVE,
PLANNED PREGNANCY AND ALL,
AND THEN, UM,
HE DIDN'T WANT US NO MORE.
IT'S HARD FOR ME BECAUSE
I DID EVERYTHING BY THE BOOK.
OUR BABY WAS WANTED,
AND THEN MY HUSBAND
PUT ME AND MY DAUGHTER OUT
IN FEBRUARY IN COLD WEATHER.
MY DAUGHTER AND I WERE HOMELESS
AND LIVING IN THE SHELTER.
YOU ARE IN A ROOM
WITH NO SHEETS,
WHERE THE FIRST WARNING YOU GET
IS WATCH OUT WITH THE BED BUGS.
AND YOU HAVE NO SHEETS,
SO YOU HAVE TO STAY
SLEEPING ON A CHAIR,
HOLDING YOUR CHILD.
AND THEN MY DAUGHTER
CRIED FOR MILK,
AND I DIDN'T
HAVE ANY MONEY.
WHEN YOU CAN'T FEED
YOUR OWN KID,
AND THEY'RE LOOKING UP
AT YOU AND CRYING
BECAUSE THEY'RE HUNGRY,
AND YOU'RE, LIKE,
"I DON'T HAVE
THE MONEY." YOU KNOW?
LIKE, "WAIT,
YOU GOTTA WAIT."
I THINK THAT WAS
THE HARDEST.
BUT IT MADE YOU
A STRONG PERSON.
YOU KNOW WHAT? STRONGER
AND STRONGER EVERY DAY.
THANK YOU, ESTELA.
MAYBE SHE IS A DIAMOND
IN THE ROUGH.
THIS COMPETITION
IS A FIGHT TO ME.
I HAVE MY DAUGHTER
TO WIN THIS FOR,
AND MY DAUGHTER'S LIFE.
ALL IT TAKES IS TO
GET MY FOOT IN THAT DOOR,
AND I AM NOT GONNA GET OUT.
♪♪♪
IT WAS THE BIRTHDAY PARTY,
YOU KNOW, FOR TWO GIRLS.
HOLD UP. I AM TALKING.
DING, DING, DING, LADY KAT'S
GOT SOMETHING TO SAY.
EXCUSE ME.
HOLD UP! HOLD UP!
QUIET DOWN, QUIET DOWN,
QUIET DOWN!
REDHEAD OVER THERE,
I DON'T KNOW YOUR NAME.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS-- HOLD UP,
I THOUGHT THAT WAS RUDE.
I GOT SOMETHING TO SAY.
SAY WHATEVER
YOU WANT TO SAY.
Y'ALL NEED TO ALL FIND
A HAPPY PLACE.
LADY KAT--SHE IS A HANDFUL.
CRAZY FREAK.
I SWEAR TO GOD.
SHE NEEDS TO STAY
THE... AWAY FROM ME,
'CAUSE I WILL SLAP HER.
DON'T TELL ME WHAT'S NOT
RIGHT OR WRONG
ABOUT MY PERSONALITY.
SHUT THE... UP!
YOU KNOW, I'M JUST LOOKING
AT THEM, AND I'M, LIKE, "DAMN.
THAT'S THE WAY
I USED TO ACT?"
♪♪♪
I'M, LIKE, READY TO GO OUT,
READY TO GET, LIKE, STRESS
OFF OF MY--OFF OF MY BACK.
WE GET TO GRIFFITH PARK,
WE'RE, LIKE, ALL EXCITED.
WE'RE, LIKE, YAY!
BEING LITTLE GIRLS ABOUT IT.
I LOVE THAT WE ARE
OUTSIDE RIGHT NOW.
IT'S GREAT.
THERE ARE BEES ALL OVER.
(screaming)
THEY ARE EVERYWHERE!
I WAS WALKING THROUGH
THE GRASS, AND THERE'S,
LIKE, BEES JUST FLYING UP
FROM EVERYWHERE
AND I'M NOT USED TO BEES
JUST FLYING AND TOUCHING ME.
YOU NEED TO MOVE, GIRL.
YOU NEED TO MOVE.
WE'LL WALK THIS WAY.
DURING THE BIRTHDAY
CELEBRATION,
LADY KAT
CUSSED EVERYBODY OUT.
HOLD UP, HOLD UP, HOLD UP.
SHE'S A LITTLE LIKE ME.
I USED TO BE LIKE HER.
BE ON YOUR BEST BEHAVIOR,
'CAUSE IT'S NOT WORTH IT.
YOU'RE HERE FOR A REASON,
NOT TO BEAT UP ON EVERYBODY.
I FELT THAT WAS MY PLACE,
TO STEP IN AND GIVE HER
THE MOST ADVICE THAT I CAN,
YOU KNOW, JUST CHILL.
BUT I'M STILL
COMPETING AGAINST HER.
THESE BEES ARE CRAZY.
OH, TAKE THAT.
(laughter)
HELLO.
MY NAME IS MARY,
AND THIS IS MY SECOND CHANCE.
GOOD SEEIN' YOU AGAIN.
I AM NOT GONNA PULL BACK,
I'M NOT GONNA NOT SHOW MY
EMOTION WHEN I SHOULD'VE,
SO THEY REALLY KNOW
WHO I AM.
WHAT WAS GOIN'
THROUGH YOUR MIND
WHEN YOU DIDN'T MAKE IT
LAST TIME?
I FELT LIKE SOMETHING
HAD JUST BEEN RIPPED OUT.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
IN MY LIFE
I FELT LIKE I'D BEEN ALIVE,
LIKE, I WAS, LIKE, WOW,
I'M DOIN' WHAT I WANT
TO DO, AND I'M SO EXCITED,
AND I'M SO CONFIDENT.
AND THEN, I DON'T KNOW,
IT WAS HORRIBLE.
I HOPE THIS CAN
HAPPEN FOR ME.
SO, RACHEL,
WHY ARE YOU HERE?
WHY AM I HERE? WHY NOT?
YOU'D BE REPRESENTING
MORE OF A PLUS SIZE.
I'M DOWN WITH THAT.
MY COMPETITION IS EVERYBODY,
WHETHER THEY ARE SKINNY AND TALL
OR VOLUPTUOUS AND
LARGER THAN ME.
ANYTHING THAT I CAN DO,
I'LL DO IT.
AS LONG AS
I AIN'T SHOWING NIPPLE,
I'M GOOD TO GO.
MY GRANDPARENTS ARE DEAD.
I HAVE NO ONE
TO DISGRACE.
HI.
MY NAME IS ALEXANDRIA.
I AM 19, AND I AM FROM
FORT COLLINS, COLORADO.
GROWING UP, THEY KINDA
WANTED ME IN SPECIAL ED,
JUST BECAUSE I HAD A REALLY
BAD SPEECH IMPEDIMENT.
THEY ACTUALLY HAD ME
ON THE SHORT BUS.
"OH, THE SPECIAL BUS
IS WAITING FOR YOU."
A LOT OF ACTORS AND MODELS
AND A LOT OF MUSICIANS
RODE THE SHORT BUS
TO SCHOOL.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU KNOW
THAT, BUT IT'S TRUE.
NO BIG DEAL.
I SEE MYSELF
DOING SOMETHING EXTRAORDINARY
WITH MY LIFE.
HAVING PEOPLE
SEE ME FOR WHO I AM.
- BYE.
MY NAME'S CHRISTINA.
I'M 24,
AND I LIVE IN TALLAHASSEE
AND GO TO FLORIDA STATE.
DO YOU TAN?
I DO LAY OUT,
SOMETIMES, YES.
OKAY, YOU LOOKIN' LIKE
MY COUSIN.
YOU LOOKIN' A LITTLE
NEGRO OVER THERE.
I'M FROM FLORIDA. SORRY.
YOU SEEM TO HAVE A, LIKE,
A REALLY TOUGH EXTERIOR.
I MEAN,
I DO HAVE CONFIDENCE.
AND I'M NOT GONNA LIE,
I AM NOT COCKY, BUT I DO,
LIKE, CARRY MYSELF WELL.
I ALWAYS HAVE.
WHEN PEOPLE FIRST MEET ME,
THEY'RE LIKE,
"OH, SHE'S STUCK UP."
YOU KNOW WHAT?
IT REALLY DOESN'T EVEN
FAZE ME ANYMORE.
- (Foreign accent) BRITA.
- (Foreign accent) HI, BRITA.
HI. HOW ARE YOU GUYS?
DID YOUR MOM AND DADDY
TALK LIKE THIS?
YES.
MY PARENTS
ARE FROM LATVIA.
- (normal voice) WHERE IS THAT?
- IT'S NEXT TO LITHUANIA,
WHICH MORE PEOPLE
HAVE HEARD OF.
GROWING UP, I MIGHT HAVE
BEEN TRAVELING THE WORLD.
THIS IS MY FRONT DOOR.
WE HAD A NICE HOUSE,
WE HAD DECENT CARS.
SO YOU GREW UP
REALLY WEALTHY?
PRETTY WEALTHY,
COMPARED TO MOST PEOPLE.
AND NOW YOU'RE
A WAITRESS.
MY DAD BROKE HIS BACK,
SO HE COULDN'T
SUPPORT OUR FAMILY.
PRETTY MUCH, I'VE JUST
BEEN KIND OF ON MY OWN.
I PAY MY OWN BILLS.
PEOPLE TALK DOWN TO ME
BECAUSE I AM A WAITRESS.
THAT'S FINE.
I AM TRYING TO STRIVE
FOR SOMETHING ELSE.
THAT'S WHY I AM HERE.
I'M TRYING
TO PURSUE MY DREAM.
MY NAME'S NOELLE
AND I'M REPRESENTIN'
RENO, NEVADA.
THIS IS A PICTURE
OF ME AND MY SON.
I HAD A BABY
KIND OF YOUNG.
NOT THAT I REGRET IT
AT ALL.
TELL ME YOUR EXPERIENCE
ABOUT BEING YOUNG
AND BEING PREGNANT,
THE GUY.
WELL, I'M STILL WITH HIM.
WE'VE BEEN TOGETHER
FOR THREE AND A HALF YEARS.
WE DIDN'T KNOW I WAS PREGNANT
UNTIL I WAS FIVE MONTHS.
I HAVE ENDOMETRIOSIS,
REALLY SEVERELY.
I MEAN, I'M NOT SUPPOSED
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE KIDS.
ENDOMETRIOSIS HAS TO DO
WITH YOUR REPRODUCTIVE SYSTEM,
AND IT'S NOT CURABLE.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT
YOU'RE BORN WITH.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT YOU HAVE CONTROL OVER.
IT IS VERY PAINFUL.
I GAVE BIRTH,
AND HE CHANGED MY LIFE.
HE IS MY MIRACLE BABY.
I MEAN, I HAVE A KID.
I'M NOT SUPPOSED
TO BE ABLE TO.
I'VE GAINED A SENSE
OF SELF-CONFIDENCE
AND A FEELING OF SELF-WORTH
THAT IS JUST--
- YOU CAN'T REPLACE IT.
- THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
♪♪♪
NOW THAT WE'VE MET
EACH GIRL INDIVIDUALLY,
WE WANTED TO COMPARE THEM
NEXT TO EACH OTHER
IN A LINGERIE WALK OFF
TO SEE IF THEY COULD
SERVE IT.
ALL RIGHTY,
IT'S A WALK-OFF,
YOUR LAST CHANCE FOR
YOUR LAST IMPRESSION.
FIERCE! WORK IT!
♪ YOU GOTTA ROCK TO
THE RHYTHM WITH 'EM ♪
♪ GOT TO GIVE IT TO 'EM ♪
♪ GOT TO GIVE
A LOT MORE... ♪
- HIT IT.
- ♪ THAN THE MINIMUM ♪
♪ RAP TO THE RHYTHM
WITH 'EM ♪
♪ GOT TO GIVE IT TO 'EM ♪
- ♪ GOT TO GIVE A LOT MORE... ♪
- FIERCE!
- GO.
- ♪ ROCK TO THE RHYTHM
WITH 'EM ♪
♪ GOT TO GIVE IT TO 'EM ♪
♪ GOT TO GIVE A LOT MORE
THAN THE MINIMUM... ♪
♪ ROCK TO THE RHYTHM
WITH 'EM ♪
♪ GOT TO GIVE IT TO 'EM ♪
♪ GOT TO GIVE A LOT MORE ♪♪
SO HOW WAS THIS
WHOLE PROCESS?
FINE.
SCARY?
NERVE-RACKING?
THIS IS THE KIND OF SCARY
THAT CAN CHANGE YOUR LIVES.
THAT'S RIGHT.
- SO BYE-BYE.
- BYE-BYE.
♪♪♪
(applause)
YOU GUYS BEEN HAVING FUN?
YES!
YEAH, BUT WE KNOW WHAT
I HAVE TO SAY, RIGHT?
YEAH.
TOMORROW MORNING, WE'RE HAVING
OUR BIG ELIMINATION.
FIRST THING IN THE MORNING,
ALARGE PORTION OF YOU GIRLS
ARE GONNA HAVE TO GO HOME.
UNFORTUNATELY, I GOT TO
LEAVE YOU WITH THAT TONIGHT.
GOOD LUCK TO ALL OF YOU,
THOUGH.
I DO HAVE THAT
NERVOUSNESS INSIDE OF ME
THAT HOPES THAT
I'M NOT GOING HOME.
THANK YOU, JESUS.
WE ASK YOU TO COME
INTO OUR CAREERS, GOD.
THIS IS MY DREAM,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
I BELIEVE WHAT GOD
HAS FOR ME IS FOR ME.
SO IF THIS IS FOR ME,
I'M GONNA GET IT.
AMEN.
GOD, I AM SO NERVOUS.
I AM PETRIFIED.
OH. IT'S OKAY.
WE WERE ALL IN THERE CRYING
LIKE WE WAS ON "OPRAH."
HEY, YOU GUYS,
ALL THAT MAKEUP IS GONE.
Y'ALL ARE SOME UGLY BITCHES.
IT'D BE HARD GETTING CUT.
WELL, THEM GETTIN' CUT.
IT'S GONNA BE HARD.
♪♪♪
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
THEY'RE GOING TO CUT NOW.
HOPEFULLY I'M NOT
ONE OF THEM.
WE NOW HAVE
TO DO OUR FIRST CUT.
AND WE'RE GONNA GO DOWN
FROM 35 TO...
20.
IN THE ROOM BEHIND ME,
THERE ARE 20 PORTFOLIOS
ON THE TABLE.
EACH PORTFOLIO HAS A PHOTOGRAPH
OF ONE GIRL INSIDE,
AND THOSE PHOTOGRAPHS
REPRESENT THE 20 WOMEN
THAT WILL BE MOVING ON TO
THE NEXT LEVEL OF COMPETITION
ON "AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL."
I'VE NEVER HAD TO GO
THROUGH ANYTHING LIKE THIS.
IT'S THE MOST NERVOUS
I EVER HAVE BEEN.
ARE YOU READY?
(screaming)
(both)
ONE, TWO, THREE.
(all taking at once)
SOON AS YOU WALK IN
THAT ROOM,
DOUBT FREAKIN' KNOCKS YOU
RIGHT IN THE BACK OF THE HEAD.
YOU KNOW, REALLY,
AM I GONNA TO MAKE THIS?
YES!
OH, THANK YOU SO MUCH!
LIFE IS LOOKING UP.
I GOT A PORTFOLIO,
SO I'M LOVING IT RIGHT NOW.
I GOT ONE.
MICHELLE.
WHERE ARE YOU, MICHELLE?
OH, HELL YEAH!
I AM FEELING TOTAL TEARS
OF JOY RIGHT NOW.
THEY DIDN'T PICK
ANY OTHER PLUS SIZE GIRLS
FOR ME
TO EVEN COMPETE WITH.
I CAN BE AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP PLUS SIZE MODEL.
I WASN'T CRYING
WHEN I SAW MY BOOK.
BUT I CRIED WHEN I SAW THEM
NOT HAVING A BOOK.
AND JUST TO SEE THESE GIRLS,
IT'S SO HARD.
I DIDN'T MAKE THE CUT.
SOMETHING SO BIG THAT
YOU'VE WANTED FOR SO LONG.
AND IT'S OFFICIALLY
OVER NOW.
STOP CRYING.
CRYING IS FOR LOSERS.
I FEEL GREAT
'CAUSE I AM STILL LIVIN'.
I HAVE NINE LIVES.
RAWR.
I WILL WIN THIS SUCKER.
BEING ABLE TO BE HERE
AND ACTUALLY SEE THE DREAM
IN THE PROCESS OF COMING TRUE
IS SO AMAZING.
HOLLA BACK. IT WORKED.
ALL OF THE GIRLS
ARE INCREDIBLE.
I'M SERIOUSLY IMPRESSED.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THEY'RE
GONNA NARROW IT DOWN.
THE COMPETITION, YOU KNOW,
IT'S A LITTLE HARDER NOW
SO I KNOW I HAVE TO
PUT MY BEST FOOT FORWARD.
I WENT TOO FAR WITH THIS
TO GO BACK.
WHO WILL MAKE
THE FINAL 14?
DON'T GO AWAY-- THERE'S MORE
"TOP MODEL" COMING UP.
♪♪♪
THE REMAINING 20 GIRLS
WALKED DOWNSTAIRS
AFTER THE FIRST CUT,
AND WE WALKED INTO A ROOM.
THIS IS YOUR FIRST
PICTURE ASSIGNMENT,
SO GET IN THE PHOTO BOOTH
AND TAKE YOUR OWN PICTURES.
I'M TRYING TO THINK OF
FOUR DIFFERENT POSES TO DO.
- I KNOW. ME TOO.
- I CAN THINK OF ONE.
I DEFINITELY THINK THE JUDGES
ARE LOOKING FOR, YOU KNOW,
US TO GET
IN THIS PHOTO BOOTH
AND BASICALLY JUST SHOW
OUR PERSONALITY.
FLUTTER YOUR EYELASHES.
I'M NOT NERVOUS
ABOUT THE PHOTO SHOOT.
JUST NERVOUS 'CAUSE I KNOW
THEY'RE GOING TO BE JUDGING IT.
♪♪♪
OH, THIS IS NOT WORKING.
I WAS, LIKE, TRYING
TO CATCH THE CAMERA.
THEN I'M LIKE,
I'M LIKE, YOU KNOW WHAT?
FORGET IT. I'M JUST GONNA
LOOK AT THE CAMERA,
SO MY PICTURES
CAME OUT PRETTY MESSED UP.
SCREW THIS THING.
THAT WAS, LIKE, THE FIRST
OPPORTUNITY TO SIZE UP
THE REST OF MY COMPETITION,
AND I TOTALLY WANTED
TO GIVE SOMETHING DYNAMIC.
THAT'S IT.
I AM GONNA BE MYSELF.
YOU KNOW, IF YOU LEARN THINGS
FROM OTHER GIRLS,
CERTAIN POSES
AND CERTAIN VOGUES...
WOW, THAT LOOKS GOOD.
LET'S TRY IT OUT ON ME.
ESTELA.
♪♪♪
THIS LITTLE MACHINE
TAKES GOOD PICTURES.
YEAH.
HELLO, MY FIERCE MR. JAY,
MISS J.
- MISS T.
- HEY.
WE HAVE 20 GIRLS HERE.
WE HAVE TO NARROW IT DOWN
TO 14,
AND THEY'LL BE
MOVING INTO THE HOUSE.
OKAY, SO KEENYAH.
KEENYAH--
SHE WAS A LITTLE FLAT.
YOU DON'T NEED EVERYBODY
TO BE CRAZY.
I AM NOT CRAZY.
ALL RIGHT. TATIANA.
SHE MAY GET A LITTLE ROUGH
AROUND THE EDGES.
ANY GIRL THAT CAN LOOK
THIS FIERCE IN A PHOTO BOOTH
IS WORTH TAKING
A SECOND LOOK AT.
JENNIFER B.
I LOVE A GIRL THAT HAS
A HORRIBLE RUNWAY WALK,
BECAUSE IT GIVES YOU
SO MUCH TO WORK WITH.
KAHLEN.
THERE'S SOMETHING
I LIKE ABOUT A GIRL
WHO DOESN'T KNOW
WHAT SHE'S DOING
BECAUSE THAT MEANS
THERE'S THE POTENTIAL
TO REALLY TEACH HER
SOMETHING.
LLUVY.
I LOVE THE SHELLEY DUVALL,
LIZA MINNELLI THING
GOING ON HERE IN THE EYES.
- GIRAFFE LASHES.
- YES.
SHE'S A LITTLE PEAR-SHAPED.
NOELLE--
I THINK THAT GIRL POPS.
THE BRIGHTNESS AND THE SHINE
THAT COMES FROM WITHIN,
IT MAKES ME WANT
TO SEE HER IN PICTURES.
BUT, TYRA, CAN I SAY NO?
- NO.
- OOH!
BRITTANY.
BRITTANY LOOKS EXACTLY
LIKE JANICE DICKINSON.
NAIMA--SHE'S SO EDGY.
SHE'S JUST, LIKE, MM!
EDGY IS ONE THING,
BUT CAN WE TAKE HER FURTHER?
- MICHELLE D.
- YOU KNOW HOW I FEEL
ABOUT NO-NECK MONSTERS.
SHE'S GOT A NECK,
SHE JUST DOESN'T KNOW
HOW TO CARRY HERSELF
IN A ROOM YET.
BRANDY.
DO YOU KNOW
WHAT I DON'T LIKE?
THE WEAVE HER MOM
DID FOR HER.
I LOVE BRANDY'S HAIR.
IN FACT, SHE'S FIERCE.
LINDSEY.
SHE'S A MODEL
FROM HERE DOWN.
AND MARIE OSMOND
FROM THERE UP.
- BRITA.
- I THINK SHE'S BEAUTIFUL
AND EVERYTHING IS GOING
SO GLAMOROUS IN FASHION,
SHE COULD LEND HERSELF
WELL TO THAT.
OKAY. SARAH.
I LOVE THIS GIRL'S FACE.
SHE CAN GIVE YOU
SOMETHING.
ESTELA.
JUST BECAUSE OF HER STORY,
I WANT TO HAVE HER
ON BOARD.
BUT THAT'S NOT A REASON TO
BRING A MODEL INTO THE HOUSE.
THERE IS SO MUCH DEADLY
WALK IN THAT GIRL.
I THINK SHE HAS
SOMETHING TO OFFER.
REBECCA.
I THINK SHE'S
A CLEAN PALATE.
SHE'S GOT THAT LITTLE
SHORT SIMPLE BLOND HAIR.
BUT REBECCA'S A LITTLE
ACTRESS LOOKING,
AND THAT MIGHT
NOT WORK FOR HER.
LADY KAT.
- I LOVE LADY KAT'S BODY...
- YEAH.
AND I DO LOVE HER FACE.
TIFFANY.
THERE'S SOMETHING
ABOUT TIFFANY
THAT I FEEL THAT WE CAN BUILD
AND MAKE HER MORE VERSATILE.
I THINK LADY KAT IS GONNA
GIVE US ONE THING.
ONE, TWO, THREE.
RAWR.
MARY. LOOK AT THAT COMMERCIAL
LITTLE SHOT OF HER.
LOOK AT THIS TOP SHOT.
SHE LOOKS SO BEAUTIFUL.
YEAH, BUT I DON'T THINK
IT IS FAIR, TYRA,
WHEN YOU PUT ONE GIRL
TO COMPETE WITH OTHER GIRLS
- THAT ARE NOT THE SAME SIZE.
- MM-HMM.
EVERYBODY HAS THEIR FAVORITES,
BUT SIX GIRLS HAVE TO GO HOME.
♪♪♪
GOD, I DON'T THINK I HAVE
EVER WANTED THIS MORE
IN MY LIFE.
I FEEL IT WITH ALL
OF MY HEART AND MY SOUL.
IF I WERE TO
WIN THIS COMPETITION,
IT WOULD CHANGE
EVERYTHING.
ME AND MY DAUGHTER--
IT WOULD JUST BE A BLESSING.
A BLESSING.
I'M SO HAPPY TO BE HERE.
IT'S JUST SO MUCH.
IT'S OVERWHELMING,
AND I'M JUST USED TO
FAILING AT EVERYTHING.
BACK HOME, EVEN THOUGH
MY GRANDMOTHER LOVED ME,
IT'S A DOUBT IN THEIR MIND
THAT TIFFANY MIGHT NOT DO IT.
♪♪♪
- HI, LADIES.
- HI.
THIS IS
THE FINAL ELIMINATION.
THOUSANDS UPON THOUSANDS
OF GIRLS WAITED IN THOSE LINES
THAT YOU ALL WAITED IN
FOR HOURS AND HOURS,
BUT THEY'RE NOT HERE.
YOU ALL ARE HERE.
AND THAT MAKES YOU
EXTRA SPECIAL.
AND I CHOSE EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF YOU TO BE HERE.
14 GIRLS TONIGHT WILL BE
IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME THAT
I'M GOING TO CALL...
REBECCA.
CHRISTINA.
KEENYAH.
THE NEXT NAME...
BRITA.
NAIMA.
OH, MY GOD.
- THANK YOU.
- YOU'RE WELCOME.
NOELLE.
OH, MY GOD.
THE SEVENTH NAME...
MICHELLE.
OH, YES!
OH, YEAH! YEAH!
SARAH.
OH, MY GOD.
BRANDY.
(cries)
HOW DO YOU FEEL,
BRANDY?
I JUST THANK GOD FOR BEING
IN THIS LINE RIGHT NOW.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I AM GOING TO CALL...
- BRITTANY!
- OH, MY GOD!
YES! I WAS WAITING
FOR MY NAME!
YEAH, YEAH!
OH, MY GOD.
I WAS GETTIN' SO SCARED.
OH, MY GOD. OH, MY GOD.
OH, MY GOD.
KAHLEN.
HOLD ON. WHAT?
YOU HEARD HER RIGHT.
I JUST DIDN'T BREATHE
FOR TEN MINUTES STRAIGHT.
(laughter)
I HAVE THREE NAMES LEFT.
THE NEXT NAME THAT I AM
GOING TO CALL--
TATIANA.
COME HERE.
LLUVY.
I HAVE SEVEN BEAUTIFUL GIRLS
STANDING BEFORE ME...
SEVEN BEAUTIFUL GIRLS THAT CAME
FROM ALL ACROSS THIS COUNTRY...
SEVEN BEAUTIFUL GIRLS THAT
ARE BEAUTIFUL ON THE INSIDE
AS WELL AS THE OUTSIDE.
BUT I ONLY HAVE
ONE NAME LEFT.
THE LAST NAME THAT I CALL
WILL COMPLETE THIS GROUP
OVER HERE
AND WILL BE
THE 14th FINALIST.
THE LAST NAME THAT
I'M GOING TO CALL...
TIFFANY.
(cheering)
TIFFANY, YES!
OH, MY HEART.
DON'T CRY, GIRL.
- YES! YES!
- WHOO!
GRANDMA, I'M GOIN' ON.
- I'M GLAD SHE MADE IT.
- OH, DON'T CRY, HONEY.
NO, I'M HAPPY FOR HER.
I WANT HER TO HAVE IT.
I'M REALLY DISAPPOINTED.
I JUST FEEL LIKE
MY HEART'S BROKEN.
I FEEL LIKE I'VE--I'VE--
I'VE COME SO FAR
AND TO MAKE IT THIS FAR
AND BE SHUT DOWN TWICE,
I JUST-- I JUST
DON'T UNDERSTAND.
OKAY?
ALL RIGHT, HONEY.
THIS WAS GONNA BE
A TRANSFORMATION
FOR THE POSITIVE
FOR ME AND MY DAUGHTER,
BUT REGARDLESS OF THE FACT,
WE WILL COME OUT ON TOP.
SO I WISH
ALL THE LADIES LUCK.
DREAMS CAN'T BE THIS GOOD.
THEY'VE NEVER FELT
THIS GOOD BEFORE.
I MADE IT. YES.
I AM SORRY, HONEY.
YES!
OH, MY GRANDMA
GON' BE SO HAPPY.
I WENT FROM
AMERICA'S MOST WANTED
TO AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
I'M SO HAPPY.
I'M JUST HAPPY.
CHILD, MY GRANDMA--
GRANDMA...
♪♪♪
STAY TUNED FOR SCENES
FROM OUR NEXT EPISODE.
COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
FASHION POLICE.
FOR THEIR FIRST PHOTO SHOOT,
THE GIRLS ARE PUT TO THE TEST
BY THE BEST...
THERE'S PEOPLE
WALKING AROUND.
THE NEW NEIGHBORHOOD DOESN'T
MEET THEIR EXPECTATIONS...
BUT IT'S THEIR ATTITUDE
AT THE MAKEOVERS...
TWO OF YOU PISSED ME OFF.
THAT CROSSES THE LINE.